hallo mein name ist luca letztlich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video weht
schon im titel eingeblendet wir machen
heute so ein test ob ein bild fake ist
oder echt hat so circa jeder youtuber
irgendwie schon mal gemacht
das habe ich mir einfach ein video
rausgesucht von thomas brill und zwar
schreibt er dort als erste szene we have
been some pretty unbelievable images an
die internet- und thomas das ist richtig
wir haben schon alle unmögliche
behindern was aber ich hier eigentlich
negativ aus dienst am pulli anblick will
images und wie internet sometimes der ob
wie es felix barth oft mit pretty
hardtail also was er uns damit was ich
sagen möchte ist dass wir alle irgendwie
schon mal bilder im internet gesehen
haben wo wir uns im ersten moment
gedacht haben okay ist das jetzt fähig
ist das echte man konnte es halt im
ersten moment so gar nicht richtig raus
finden und dann legt man am ende so yao
das muss auf jeden fall fähig sein und
deshalb eine echt und man denkt sich nur
so you think you have an iphone appstore
link between rio entfernt ist as you'll
be shown that of images die hefte figure
out of reach image ist ein exilant
us-fotograf auf fake images result vom
foto manipulation also wir werden jetzt
sehr viele bilder eingeblendet bekommen
die einerseits entweder echt sein oder
fake sind und dann müssen wir quasi
raten ok muss es irgendwie recht sein
ist es echt ist es fällt keine ahnung
was und danach kommt die auflösung also
ob seine photoshop wurde oder wirklich
eine reale fotografie von etwas ist
remember to count up how many questions
aquaclean vettel vier score comment
below or other words leute können sogar
selber mitmachen und zwar schreibt
einfach in die kommentare wie viele
sachen ihr wirklich richtig erraten
konnte begin the pictures
nummer 1 das erste bild wird uns als
dieses hier angezeigt also wir haben
eine menge bäume und die sind unten alle
rot und oben alle grünen im ersten
moment würde ich halt sagen ist ein fake
aber wenn das halt echt oder fake ist
dann ist er wieder so ein bisschen
tricky also ich finde an dieser stelle
sieht man das ganz krass und 2 der baum
hier wirklich rot und hier vorne ist er
hier hinten rot das heißt wenn das ge
photoshop worden wäre und die untere
hälfte des bildes wäre einfach rot
gemacht worden dann hätte das ja alles
hier eine linie sein müssen und hier am
rand sieht man auch dass das hier ein
bisschen weiter und rotes und hier ein
bisschen weiter oben rot das heißt ich
glaube das ist wirklich echt wie klicken
einfach mal auf play und warten jetzt ab
was diese zeit hier sagt okay da unten
spielt sie jetzt erstmal ab wie lange
man zeit aber ich möchte mal so ein
bisschen kommentieren deswegen mach ich
das wohl noch ein bisschen wir haben
noch einen moment übrig und wir sehen
die antwort wird uns jetzt eingeblendet
und zwar ist es real
die erste mass of 2001 toxic waste
investor also im west ungarn gab es wohl
irgendwas mit verschiedenen giften und
das ist irgendwie durch diesen wald
geschwommen und dadurch wurden die bäume
halt unterschiedlich rot ist krasser ist
halt einfach ich habe ja selber zu
beginn gedacht dass das alles an gemalt
wurde dass deswegen unterschiedliche
höhen sind aber hey wir hatten zumindest
richtig dass hier ist das zweite bild
und zwar eine fotografie von einem typen
der hier an mehreren balance ist und
schwebt
hoch
ich glaube nicht dass man von so wenig
balance schon fliegen kann das bild an
sich ist super cool also dass es wird
man eigentlich mit jeder kamera zu
hinkriegen die ein bisschen
professioneller als also einfach einen
sonnenuntergang bis iso werte angepasst
dass das ganze hier ein bisschen heller
ist und da ist halt einfach so ein typ
und ich glaube wirklich dass es fähig
ist nicht weil das bild so krass fake
aussieht sondern einfach weil mensch
glaube ich nicht mit 1 89 luftballons
fliegen kann
wir warten mal eben die zeit hier unten
noch ab die jetzt gerade abgelaufen ist
sehen jetzt ernster eingeblendet also
die antwort photoshop ich warte jetzt
jemand eben noch ob irgendein text
eingeblendet wird von wegen aber als ok
es kam kein text also das dritte bild
meine damen und herren ist dieses hier
[Musik]
was ist das
es ist der himmel jetzt also wir hatten
bisher echt und photoshop das heißt
theoretisch könnte es wieder recht sein
wenn man dem dem rhythmus danach geht
aber ich glaube sogar wirklich dass das
echt ist weil man kann eigentlich nicht
so krass etwas foto shoppen mit diesen
bäumen auch so genau und dass das sieht
schon also man ich glaube es ist ein
bisschen die intention von diesem thomas
april von dem das video ist ich hab's
euch übrigens auch bei einer
beschreibung verlinkt also lasst ihn
kommentar der mega lieb dass er das
quasi zur verfügung gestellt hat glaubt
das ist echt das kann wirklich sein dass
so krass gewitter mal aussehen kann
wir warten die restliche zeit ab das
bild wird ausgeblendet wir sehen erste
und es ist viele leute okay dass
fotograf schoss in new zealand cloud
sunset was geht ab ich habe bisher alles
richtig alter ich habe mir das video
nicht vorher angeguckt ich habe nur
gesehen dass erst auf seinem kanal
hochgeladen hat dieses areal of
photoshop und wollte einfach selber mal
schauen ob das jetzt reloader fake ist
sie also ähnlich wie dieses quiz was ich
letztens von tahir hochgeladen habe mein
name ist luca aber wie gesagt schreibt
meine kommentare wir das auch richtig
hart aber ich finde sogar bisher war es
relativ easy also aber mal schauen wie
es jetzt weitergeht das ist das vierte
bild
ich würde wirklich auf den ersten moment
sagen fähig weil das ist definitiv fähig
es kann nicht sein dass da so viele
fucking sternschnuppen oder meteoriten
oder was weiß ich einfach aus dem aus
dem sonnensystem verlässlich da hinten
aus dem weltall tools gesandt werden das
ist eigentlich ein typischer apple
hintergrund finde ich so mit diesem
weltall einblendungen und so aber ich
glaube wenn ich mich jetzt entscheiden
müsste würde ich sagen verläuft als ente
das ist photoshop ist
ich hoffe es ja alles richtig das fünfte
bild was heute eingeblendet wird es
dieses bild von einer eule
[ __ ] alter
existieren solche eulen ich bin mir
nicht sicher also ich finde wenn man
sich das bild war wirklich betrachtet
sieht man auch dass hier unten das ganze
so ein bisschen verschwommen ist und
auch so ein bisschen zu krass aussieht
von der sättigung von den allgemeinen
farben die dort verwendet wurden
deswegen würde ich sagen dass es auch
fake ist also die eule sieht zwar schon
echt aus und es gibt bestimmt irgendwo
tropenwäldern oder im regenwald oder
keine ahnung und leben der beulen ich
dumm es gibt locker irgendwo solche
kunterbunten tiere aber also ich meine
wenn ich das komplette bild anschaut ist
es mir so ein bisschen zur sättigung
reich also warten wir auf die antwort
und es ist auch ge photoshop alter leute
warten was geht gerade ab wie heftig ich
habe einfach alles richtig ich weiß
nicht wie es euch gerade geht oder wie
viel hier dann richtig habt aber ich
habe einfach entweder mega das glück
oder mega das gute auge ein paar
sekunden später ok wack
age
ich würde wirklich sagen echt weil man
sieht wirklich auch das hier vom haus
aus weggerissen wurde das kann halt echt
sein dass da einfach ins und erdrutsche
war oder wenn das an weil sie nicht an
irgendeiner wie heißt das wenn wo diese
platten aneinander sind die continental
scheiben kontinentalplatten ich weiß ich
hätte nie erdkunde so richtig aber die
platten aneinander sind entstehen
erdbeben und das kann sein dass das
irgendwie dadurch entstanden ist also
ich würde wirklich sagen es ist echt ist
sollte das ganze fähig sein dann ist es
mega gut gefällt worden also ich finde
dann müsste man auch dieses haus da oben
also krass machen aber wir warten mal
auf die antwort und zwar ist es echt des
images ist single what happened in
guatemala city in may 2010 also dieses
bild zeigt wirklich in so ein erdloch wo
irgendetwas alles runter gerutscht ist
und dass es passiert in guatemala im mai
2010 aber kommen wir zum siebten bild
meine damen und herren und zwar ist es
das hier
alter schwede ist das eine kirche auf
diesem feld drauf ich weiß auf jeden
fall dass es diesem feld gibt ich war da
zwar selbst noch nie habe ich habe den
gesehen drauf im instagram profil von
casey nice day die schau mal ganz kurz
ob ich das bild noch mal finde dass
casey mitten im meer vor diesem felsen
also ich glaube das wird er sein wenn
ich hier an summe dann ist dort kein
gebäude drauf das heißt ich würde sagen
dass ganzes photoshop jetzt sagen locker
welche lu carlos hier geschieht hat sie
nebenbei irgendwo nachgeguckt und keine
ahnung was habe ich hab ich ja schon
vorher gesagt dass das bild schon mal
gesehen habe deswegen wir warten jetzt
einfach mal die antwort ab und wir sehen
es ist photoshop leute das testament
wird genau wie halt dein maul kommen wir
nun zum achten von zehn bildern und zwar
ist dieses hier wo eine person einen
rückwärtssalto macht über den wellen
oder über dem ozean oder wenn es eine
wüste ist keine ahnung was im
hintergrund ist die sonne
leute also ich finde sie nicht mehr
schwierig also ich würde sagen es ist
safe real ist alter regisafe rüdiger
wahrscheinlich hat er einfach ein
rückwärtssalto irgendwie vor allem brot
gemacht oder so und sieht so aus als ob
er wirklich die sonne umarmt es ist
einfach ein sehr krasses bild also ich
hab jetzt einfach mal auf play off
weiter gedrückt ihr seht die uhr läuft
unten aber wie gesagt leute schreibt
jetzt einfach in die kommentare bis
richtig haben wir sehen schon ende
eingeblendet und wir sehen es photoshop
was
dieses bild
doch niemals photoshop er sich hätte
wirklich von allen bildern die wir
bisher hatten gesagt dass das hier safe
das allererste ist
das enttäuscht mich gerade dass er sich
richtig habe ich glaube nicht dass man
sowas foto shoppen kann natürlich kann
man eigentlich nahezu alles irgendwie
mit photoshop richtig bearbeiten oder
keine ahnung was aber das sieht mir doch
schon wirklich sehr echt aus wir warten
einfach mal noch die letzten sekunden
hier ab bei dem bild das heißt jetzt mit
ihr wieder eingeblendet also ich sage es
ist echt und es ist wirklich real wo ich
dachte schon jetzt ist meine strähne
komplett zu ende hier mit den ganzen
erwarten dass hier ist das letzte bild
was wir heute erraten müssen und das
essay photoshop weil als wenn eine katze
so in einem berg drin ist ich weiß nicht
ob es eine karte zu sein soll es kann
joachim im jaguar sein oder keine ahnung
was aber es ist auf jeden fall in einem
berg drin und es ist nicht so wie dieses
merkmal von diesen ganzen präsidenten
oder menschen in den berg drin aber es
ist auf jeden fall photoshop wie es auch
schon gesagt habe das heißt jetzt
zusammenfassend gesagt hatte ich neun
von zehn richtig dass videos jetzt auch
vorbei der fragt uns zu how to do all so
schreibt es einfach mal runter in die
kommentare
wie ihr das ganze jetzt hier vollendet
haben also wie viele sachen die wirklich
richtig hatte und seit ernst also
schreibt jetzt nicht alle zehn von zehn
oder so sonst würde ich sagen was uns
jetzt auch hier vor dem heutigen video
wenn ihr möchtet dass ich so was
ähnliches vielleicht normal mache last
auf jeden fall mal ein like da ihr
findet jetzt mal die eingeblendet wenn
er darauf hier könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren es ist kostenlos ihr werdet
man benachrichtigt wenn ich das neues
hoch laden und es ist
das cool und hier findet ihr ein anderes
video eingeblendet was ich irgendwann
mal hochgeladen habe also check it out